you're a director here's two faces think
about how you could compose them on
screen for a dramatic conversation
between a couple you might have them sit
across from each other and use
over-the-shoulder shots
you could have them walk beside each
other you could have them stand arguing
or you could play it in profile there
are a lot of great ways you could frame
the couple but would you come up with
this
[Music]
the face is perhaps one of the most
important and powerful dramatic tools
cinema has at its disposal
in the hands of a talented performer the
drama of a face can be one of the most
captivating parts of a film
and yet when it comes to how faces are
presented in film the way they're
composed and arranged on screen
it can be easy to fall into a rut
relying on convention to compose them in
tried and true ways that we've all seen
thousands of times maybe the greatest
exception to this the director i would
consider the master of composing faces
in unique and inventive ways is swedish
director ingmar bergman
thank you to mubi for sponsoring this
video
bergman's filmography is piercingly
intimate his
stories often have little or no action
take place in a few simple locations and
involve just a handful of characters
a few people having a conversation is
maybe the most well-tread territory in
film
yet his films are often visually
striking
and contain inventive imagery that i've
never seen anywhere else
like many directors he spins faces so we
see them straight on in direct profile
or facing away from the lens
while these types of compositions aren't
unusual in other films
what sets bergman apart is that he's not
afraid of playing even his most
important dramatic moments on a
composition like this
and he isn't afraid to linger here for
an extended period of time but more
unusually
he also rotates faces turning them
sideways and even
completely upside down beyond changing
the position of a face
you can modify its shape further by
obscuring part of it with an
object in the foreground light also
plays an important role in shaping the
face
how a face is lit dramatically changes
its texture
light can make a face foreboding or flat
with it you can even reduce
a face to a sliver the lighting doesn't
have to be static either
and persona bergman illustrates a shift
in internal emotion by subtly
changing the light on a face
in summer with monica he does something
similar but this time
he changes the light that surrounds the
face instead of the light on the face
[Music]
i think the two places he does this in
this film are its most striking moments
[Music]
using lines cast by shadows you can
divide a face
into pieces further creating unique
compositions and shapes
and persona and the seven seal costume
design is used to emphasize the faces of
certain characters
in these examples it almost disembodies
the face in one case
emphasizing the character's true nature
as a spirit
and in the other calling into question
whether the character is truly real or
just a psychological projection in cries
and whispers
two sisters faces are shrouded in black
contrasting
the third sister's face surrounded by
white
the drama of the face can be very subtle
appreciate just for a moment
the emotional detail in the small
expressions on liv ullman's face in this
scene
and our ability to extrapolate internal
conflict
just from what we see on her face and
you can tell bergman
really trusted the power of a face on
its own
in this scene from cries and whispers he
creates horrifying tension
simply by keeping the scene in close-up
it creates a feeling that something
terrible is being kept
just out of view
those are a lot of variables that give
you a lot of options for
uniquely portraying a single face but
where the potential of faces becomes
truly infinite is in the arrangement of
multiple faces in a frame
the interplay between two faces in a
frame can create an incredible variety
of compositions
you can visually contrast desire and
indifference or concern
and ecstatic bliss within a single
composition
in the seventh seal which features a
fairly large cast for bergman
he stacks faces on top of each other
arranging them in tableau
here he uses faces in symbolically
significant ways
in this scene the face of a mask
represents death's
presence looming over the party he does
a similar thing in the winter light a
film about a priest
struggling with doubt here the face of
christ looms
in the background as if he's just
another face in one of bergman's
compositions
and in this scene from the seventh seal
the two characters
in the foreground act as mouthpieces for
the words
of the characters behind them those
characters faces
sit on the shoulders of the speaking
characters like
angels and devils light again plays a
role with multiple faces
now bergman can contrast how two faces
are lit
one can be dark and one can be light one
can be evenly lit
and another split by shadow bergman
also understands intuitively the power
of obscuring a face
as humans we're drawn to see faces our
brains are highly attuned to recognized
faces
and the emotions displayed there so
we're acutely aware of the presence of a
face that we can't fully
see feeling almost cheated of the
emotional information that's just
out of sight and bergman plays with this
constantly cutting
faces off letting us see only a small
piece
or obscuring them altogether giving us
only a small piece of a face makes us
pay closer attention
to try to make out what information we
can and it can also represent a
character's attempt or
desire to hide what they truly feel
in bergman's exploration of the face
it's important to note his collaboration
with cinematographer sven nyquist
sven's stunning minimalist black and
white cinematography would help
emphasize the landscape of the face
bergman utilized faces in interesting
ways before working with fenn but
together they would push the boundaries
of what was possible even further
the collaboration started with the
virgin spring developed over several
films and perhaps reached its peak with
[Music]
persona
[Music]
so
[Music]
if bergman is the master of using the
face in unique ways in cinema
persona is perhaps the film that pushes
his use of the face to its
limit it's hard to think of a film more
thematically oriented around the
landscape of the face than persona
the idea of the face itself and the
portrayal of faces on screen
is intimately linked to the themes of
the film
not only is bergman exploring the edges
of how a face can be abstracted on
screen and composition
without losing the emotional information
that resides there
he's utilizing the face and the
interplay between two faces
to create powerful symbolism at the core
of the film
so why isn't this kind of composition
and experimentation with faces more
common in film
well to achieve what bergman's achieving
it's not just about composition
the emphasis on face runs much deeper
into production
how scenes are staged and how actors
work is affected
what's often missing from bergman cinema
is shot and reverse shot
because we often see close-ups and
reactions in the same frame
there's an added complexity not just for
individual compositions but
in the progression from one composition
to another
within single shots actors have to move
their heads and
reposition themselves at precise moments
for some of these moments bergman is
blocking scenes not just on the scale
of where actors stand but on the scale
of the turn of ahead
in this scene from cries and whispers as
two sisters try to reunite
as they push away from each other they
face away from us
concealing themselves from us and one
another but as they open up to each
other
they turn their faces towards us
literally becoming more
emotionally open to the audience as they
open up to each other
working like this is a lot to ask of
your talent especially when you're
dealing with material that's as
emotionally raw as bergman was
and without shot and reverse shot there
aren't many options here to adjust
things
in the edit and that might have been
part of why the director tended to
stick with certain actors once he'd
found ones he liked working with
most contemporary dramas are much more
geared towards giving actors flexibility
and freedom
the recent film malcolm mre has a lot of
elements that are evocative of a berkman
film
it's shot in black and white it has one
location only two characters and deals
with
interpersonal conflict there are even
some moments that seem to evoke
berkman's use of
faces but because the actors are moving
more freely
the shapes and compositions they create
with their faces are much more fleeting
and fluid
in bergman's films it's the holding of
these positions
or the precision of the movements as
much as it is their presence
that gives them a lasting impact working
this way
using the face as a landscape isn't
right for every film story style of
performance or cinematography
packing two faces close together works
well for certain kinds of scenes and
subject matter
but would be terrible for others my hope
in highlighting how bergman uses faces
is not just to inspire you by showing
you what's possible with a face
but also to showcase just how limitless
any individual aspect of film can be
and how much potential lies just outside
the boundaries
of convention in this video i've been
illustrating bergman's approach to using
faces
one i think is incredible but one of the
things i love about film is that
just because one approach works well and
produces
interesting results on screen doesn't
invalidate
other sometimes opposite approaches a
filmmaker who works much less formally
giving his actors a lot of freedom to
improvise but
who still finds interesting compositions
in the process
is derek c in france his film blue
valentine is made
using techniques dramatically different
from how bergman approached filmmaking
and yet he reaches a similar level of
dramatic effect
you can watch blue valentine right now
on mubi my sponsor for this episode
i can recommend blue valentine or other
films for you to watch on movie but what
i love most about mubi
is that it's a hand curated streaming
service on many other platforms the
films that are recommended to you
are shown to you because an algorithm
thinks you'll like it
this can be great for finding more stuff
like films you've already watched but
it's not a great way to find something
new on mubi every film is hand-picked by
their team
and they even provide an explanation for
why
they think the film is worth checking
out you can explore their library
and the new film they add every day for
free when you sign up for
an extended free trial at movie.com
thomasflight that's movie.com
thomasflight to sign up for your
extended free trial